- My question for you is this,
being here in Florida,
taking this entire
conversation that we've had,
the beautiful
weather, the freedom,
a system that's
working, flourishing,
getting rid of all the things
that you're frustrated with:
could a good liberal like you
vote for a guy
like Ron DeSantis?
(ethereal music)
All right, we are at the
newly revamped Local studio.
Look at that warm wood
in the background.
We heard your calls,
"Warm it up, guys."
And we did, here we go.
The brand new Local studio,
the brand new, brand
new Local studio.
(Peter chuckles)
I'm still old-fashioned,
Dave Rubin.
And I am joined today by my
friend, philosopher, author,
can I still call you?
You're a teacher of some sort.
- Teacher, friend, and
friend of the show.
- And friend of the show,
that's what you said
when you sat down,
more importantly
than anything else.
Friend of "The Rubin Report."
- Well, no!
It's actually not
more importantly,
our friendship is the
most important thing
and it's nice to be
a friend of the show.
- Well, it is good
to see you my friend,
Pete Boghossian, obviously.
You have not been on
the show since February,
we just checked this
February of 2019,
so quite literally four
years ago this month,
it's been a while,
a lot to catch up on.
- A lot to catch up on.
- But we booked this
thing couple weeks ago,
and then last night was the
State of the Union Address.
- So let's start
(chuckles) with our.
- So let's start with that
because something
interesting happened
and I referenced it on
my show this morning,
on my wrap-up show,
that what I see
happening in America
that I think is one of
the most disturbing trends
is that we're all
watching the same script,
we're all watching
the same movie,
and we are experiencing
wildly different things.
- Completely agree with that.
- We're seeing
completely different things,
our reactions are
completely different.
Anyway, I'm watching
that thing thinking:
this guy's a liar, a fraud;
he's obviously drugged;
these people are bringing in
all of the wrong policies;
it's a miracle he hasn't
fallen off the stage
and knocked the podium over.
I mean, all of the stuff.
And then I'm looking
at your Twitter,
and you're seemingly
impressed by what's going on,
you seem to like him,
you seem to think that it's put
to bed some of the questions
about his mental acumen,
et cetera, et cetera.
- His dementia.
(speaks faintly).
- And then I thought,
"Man, I cannot wait to
sit with Pete tomorrow."
Because we're friends,
and it does not matter
if we disagree on this stuff.
- 100%.
- But how we could view
this so differently.
Now speak.
- And so the other context
of that is you're texting me
like, "Are you drunk tweeting?
Are you serious?"
- Yeah!
Well, I thought you must be
drunk or you were hacked into
'cause you're going,
"Biden seems sharp,
this all makes sense."
- So, I guess the more
profound point is that
we can disagree
about our perception,
and we're gonna talk
about what we perceived,
but we're still buddies,
I'm still sitting here,
we're gonna hang out,
like, there's a context
for our disagreement.
So this is what I thought:
independent of the content,
the narrative that Biden is
senile or he has dementia.
I think that speech, to me, it
completely put that to rest:
he was sharp;
he was focused.
And I understand he
has a teleprompter,
I understand he has
notes in front of him.
A senile person or a
person with dementia,
I don't care if
he's on Modafinil,
whatever drug he is on,
I don't think he could have
delivered that performance,
and I'm talking
independent of content.
- Okay, so let's
put content aside.
- And we can talk
about that content.
- Sure, so we'll do the content
and the policy thing after,
but putting that aside,
so you're just talking about
his physical and mental ability
to walk up on that stage
and read that prompter,
you think that,
look, I can't diagnose him and
say for sure he has dementia
or Alzheimer's or something,
but to me, he clearly, clearly
has something wrong with him.
And that the fact that
they can prop him up
either through Adderall,
or a ton of coffee, or
God knows what they have,
whatever those drugs are.
I don't know, how do
you view that and go,
"Well, because he had a
decently cogent two hours
that overrides all
of the other video
of the stammering
and confusion-"
- Okay, two things.
- "And shaking hands
with ghosts, and
things of that nature?"
- Okay, two things.
Let's take a one step back.
The thing that changed my
mind about Donald Trump
was in Trump's second
debate with Biden,
he clearly destroyed him.
In fact,
sometimes I think Megyn Kelly
and I are the same person.
She tweeted something
like, it's all been an act.
'Cause, up at that point,
I almost never heard him
make a coherent argument,
or sentence, or statement.
- Wait, when you're
saying, "He destroyed him."
You mean Biden destroyed Trump?
- No!
In the second debate.
- Trump destroyed
in the second debate.
Oh, 'cause they were only two.
- In the second debate.
- Because they
cancel canceled one.
Right, right.
- The first one
was a catastrophe.
- The first one was not
that good for Trump.
Yes, yeah.
- But then I thought,
like, you can't go
from nothing to that.
Like you can't go
from a rambling,
incoherent, ignoramus to that.
I mean, he was on.
I think any objective
independent enquire
would've looked at that
debate and say, "Trump."
So, I think with Biden,
so this gets back
to the question,
how can two people look at it?
I think any independent person
would look at that and say,
"He was on point.
It was a good talk.
He was clear.
He does not have senility.
He does not suffer
from senility.
He's not dementia.
His points are well articulated.
He wasn't slurring."
And I realize that's a low bar.
He wasn't drooling.
- He did slur some.
He did slur some.
- Okay, so some of the words
weren't articulated or
enunciated perfectly
but I walked away from that
and I questioned a
lot of the narratives.
I also think that there's
a kind of unfairness,
no matter who's in office,
you know, when Biden pinned,
I don't know, gave blood or
something on his granddaughter,
people edited it
to make it look like he
was touching her breast,
or I think that there's
a lot of just hacks who,
if they don't like the content,
and we can talk
about the content-
- Sure, sure.
- That's fine.
- And we will get
to the content.
- But I'm just talking
about him standing up there
and delivering that performance.
I don't understand how you
could not look at that,
and drugs aside, say,
"He was on point.
That was a good talk:
he was clear;
he made arguments;
he remembered to the extent
that he's on a teleprompter;
he engaged people
in real banter."
I thought it was a great talk.
- (sighs) Okay, so we're
gonna follow through this.
- Content aside.
Content aside.
- Yeah, yeah, content aside.
So, first off, I would say that,
A, we don't know what
the drug situation is.
So I would imagine,
and I don't know enough about
the drugs that they prescribe
for cognitive decline
or whatever,
but it seems to me that
you could basically
take almost anyone probably,
unless they're at the real
end of stage with this stuff
and make them cogent
for two hours.
So I don't see how
that puts it to bed,
if anything, it seems
to me you're saying,
"There probably
are drugs out there
that can make you
somewhat functional."
- So that would be the question
to find somebody. (chuckles)
Again, this is coming from a guy
who was brought up an ethical
violation for hoax papers.
- And by the way, I would prefer
that you're right in a way,
he's still the pilot
of the plane, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So whether I agree
with the stuff or not the guy
is in charge of an awful lot.
- But hoping that I'm right
doesn't make it right,
like you would
have to find people
who suffered from similar
perceived cognitive ailments
and give them whatever
suite of drugs
and see if they could perform.
I would highly doubt it,
unless you wanna say he's
somehow like a trick pony,
and even this is territory
I'm not particularly
comfortable weighting into,
he's somehow performatively
giving a talk
he has no idea what
he is talking about,
but even then, it was
pretty impressive.
I just thought it put
to bed to rest the idea
that here's a
senile demented guy.
Now, if you've watched
videos of Joe Biden
from 20 years ago,
I mean, he's clearly
a different man,
I mean, I'll give
it to you 100%,
but that talk, I
thought he shined.
- You know, it's interesting
because I also spent,
I had two grandmothers
that both had
certain amount of dementia:
my grandmother on my mom's
side had it for longer,
and I really saw it,
and I spent a lot
of time with her.
- Yeah, I'm sorry.
- 'Cause I was doing
standup at night so during
the days I was with her,
often for days on
end, hours and hours,
and I really saw that decline.
One of the things that I noticed
that Biden seems to have,
and I've seen a lot of
people mention this also,
is there's a dysregulation
related to his
emotional response.
- Yeah, I can see that.
- So at times,
he seems very slow and quiet,
then he does that
whispering thing,
and then out of nowhere,
he starts yelling
and you don't know why.
- Oh,
you're talking
about China, yeah.
- And that China thing
where he's yelling,
it's like there was no
anger to be expressing there
but he has to emote
in a very weird way
because something back
there is not right,
again, I'm not a doctor.
- It could be a performative
thing too, though, right?
I mean, it could be like,
this is hiding speech.
- But performative almost
as if it's broken down
and it's not performing
correctly, right, like?
- Well, it wouldn't be as if
he wouldn't doing it correctly
if he broke down and
had random outbursts.
But if he has outbursts
about the same thing.
But again, I don't even
think that was an outburst,
I think he was trying
to drill home something,
maybe even to appease
the Republicans,
I don't know.
- Right, the funny thing is,
neither one of us know what
he was trying to drive home
(laughs) related to
the content part of it.
Okay, so, putting that aside,
'cause I don't wanna
spend three hours
talking about his
cognitive state,
but I think the fact that
we even don't really see that
eye to eye is interesting,
that you just feel it was
enough evidence, as you said,
"To put it to bed."
Where to me it was like,
that's not enough
evidence to put to bed,
it's enough evidence to go,
oh, I'm probably right
about this thing,
and we will probably
find out that I'm right.
And you know what I mean?
Like, think about it:
if he makes it through the term,
at some point, when
he's no longer president
or if he's had to
step down or saying,
it's all gonna come out,
he's obviously on something.
- So my main takeaway from
that was different than yours.
I think my main takeaway
is that we are so divided,
and I've lost very
close friends of mine
who have been in my house,
you know, buddies of mine
over political disputes.
- We've lost co-friends.
- Co-friends, co-friends.
So the fact that you and
I can disagree on this
and be completely cool,
like, that's the model,
like, that's what everybody
should be striving.
Look, dude, if you said,
"Listen, my kids are sick.
I know you're in
Florida for a few days.
David can't do it.
Can you help me out?"
Dude, in one second
I'd be there.
- Yeah, I know you would.
- And does it matter to
me if you think Biden
is a dribbling fool?
No, it doesn't
matter to me at all.
- It's actually more
interesting in a way
because we're all going
into our own echo chambers
whether we like it or not,
it's becoming increasingly
hard to do it,
so because I know
you as a person
and as a decent human
being, and all that,
to watch last night,
and I'm watching you tweet.
And I'm like, "This is wild!"
But it really made
me wanna sit down.
So let's talk a little
bit about the content
of some of this stuff.
I don't think of you as
a purely political beast,
but you sort of became
a political beast
because of what was going
on at Portland State
and your stance on free speech.
So maybe for people
that haven't seen our
previous interviews
or don't know too
much of your bio,
you wanna maybe hit like
a minute or two of that
just so that it has
a little context?
A Little context
to how you started talking
about politics, I guess.
- Yeah, so I experienced
a woke takeover,
or let's put it this way,
I experienced an
authoritarian takeover
fueled by an ideology,
not only for which there
was absolutely no evidence,
but for which the
evidence was against
every time I started asking,
not even questioning,
but asking for evidence:
the hammers came down;
the investigation started.
- So you were an
assistant professor of?
- Philosophy.
We did an event very
early on in my career.
- Of Christina Hoff Sommers.
- You brought Christina
Hoff Sommers and I
to Portland State
to do an event.
- And remember the SWAT teams,
the security guard,
they were everywhere,
we had to go in the room,
and they were like
shielding us, yeah.
- That was the first time,
subsequently, it's
happened all the time now.
But that was the first time
I had ever done an event
where security was needed,
where there were
protestors outside,
people screaming,
there were threats of violence,
cops everywhere.
I remember we had to go
to a separate green room
where the cops then had
to escort us to the stage.
All this craziness.
- And they had these
huge shields that were like
in case someone
shot or something.
Yeah, I remember that, yeah.
- But the point is,
you were an assistant
professor of philosophy,
a lefty, a liberal.
- Liberal.
I was never a lefty.
- Oh, okay.
So you were liberal in the
classical sense of liberalism.
But that was not good enough
for a place like Portland State.
- It was not good enough.
And it was not good enough,
it not only was
not extreme enough,
but it wasn't good
enough because to
question the orthodoxy
means you're not just
wrong, you're bad.
So enough about that,
did the hoax papers, et cetera.
- Then you wrote these hoax
papers with James Lindsay
that really caught fire,
and basically, the whole
idea was to show how
the peer-reviewed process is-
- It's ideological
and corrupt, right?
- Yeah.
- We wrote
the conceptual penis,
which we joked about before,
and everyone went crazy about,
it was a hoax paper,
they said, you know,
"You guys didn't prove
what you thought he did,
to prove it you need
to do A, B, C, D, E."
We did A, B, C, D, E.
Did anybody say, "Oh, my gosh,
you've done A, B, C, D, E,
I guess we were wrong?"
No.
Instead, they say
Boghossian is unethical
for fooling all
those journal editors
to take deranged papers.
- Because your point in doing
it was to show how nonsensical
so much of these studies are.
Studies that then-
- There's an
ideological corruption.
- They cover on CNN,
and then a politician
refers to the study.
- Right, it informs
public policy,
it's an ideological corruption,
these are the musings
of ideologues,
they discharge their moral
impulses in journals.
We've gotta clean this up,
like there's just no question.
But instead of saying like,
"Oh, geez, you know,
maybe certain disciplines
we have problems,
we need to be more rigorous."
No, it's attack the people
who're saying that
there's a problem.
- Okay,
so to relate that to
the political part
of this State of the Union
and some of the stuff that
we didn't see eye to eye on,
which I think is it's rich
that we're doing this.
So my basic position is that
virtually everything he said
was either a lie
or an intentional
obfuscation of the truth.
Something like saying gas
prices are going down,
that is technically true,
but they're significantly
higher than when he took office,
or inflation is going down,
technically true,
significantly higher
than when he took office,
we can get into some COVID
stuff and a bunch else,
but what would you say
about that general,
and by the way,
I'm not just blaming
this on Democrats
or think they all do it.
- No, no, no.
Okay, so, let's say
that you're right.
Let's say that 100%
of everything you just
articulated to me is correct.
Wouldn't the best
way to convey that
to have Sarah Huckabee gave the,
wouldn't it be to just go
through those points and say,
"Biden said this,
here's the actual
data, it's not true?"
It doesn't have
to be complicated.
You know, Ross-
- That's precisely, by the way,
what we did on my show today,
that is what we did
on my daily show.
- But that's what people do
when they participate
in a similar framework
of rationality and reality.
I didn't see that at all in her.
I don't know, did you watch?
- I did, I did.
- Okay, so she's
talking about Trump
and narratives, and the story.
No, no, no.
If you believe that
Biden said, not you,
but if one believes
the Republicans in
particular believe it,
then in the retort
to that speech,
that was like a
canned prepared song.
- Right,
so you wanted something
written on the fly, basically,
which I agree.
I agree it probably
would've been-
- He said, "This
is just not true."
And the American people need
to know why it's not true.
Like the American,
he said he's gonna trim
the debt by $2 trillion,
the whole thing about the
police was completely insane.
So I would much
rather have preferred,
forget what I
would've preferred.
If you wanna talk about
things that are true
and participate in reality,
then that follow-up talk that,
I can't remember what they,
the rebuttal, what have you?
- The rebuttal, yeah.
- Yeah, that should
have been data-driven
and talked about where Biden
was wrong and it did not.
And it was a terrible
missed opportunity.
- So I will say,
and I said it on my
show this morning,
I thought the speech itself
I thought was quite good
because I think she was dealing
with the grand narratives.
- I agree.
- I liked her line on
your basically either for
reality or for craziness,
something to that effect.
But yes, she didn't go in,
they clearly didn't
write it on the fly,
'cause then they could have done
what I did on the show this
morning and shown data.
- Or Vivek Ramaswamy
could have given a great
talk, woke capital,
I mean, he could have done that.
Okay, so, for sure.
- Okay, putting,
let's say it was flawed
or, well, let's just put
that aside for a second,
the rebuttal,
'cause very few people
actually watched the rebuttal.
In a case like this, someone
like you who cares about truth,
when you hear him
say these things,
if you're willing to
grant me the leash
that what I'm telling
you right now is true,
that gas prices, for example,
when he came in were about
2,30 they went up to five,
now they're around 3,30,
so they are higher than
when he took office,
and then he says
they're coming down.
It's a complete trick,
it's just a verbal trick.
Now, I have no
doubt Trump did it;
I have no doubt Obama did
it and everything else.
But I think something's
happening now where the lies
because of COVID are so
everywhere in society
and they have been so-
- To a post-truth world.
- Debunked in real-time
that people can't
take it anymore.
Something feels
different about the lies,
we can be lied to
a certain degree,
and I think we're crossing
a threshold with the lies
that is gonna do
something very dangerous,
something like that.
So, what are you asking then?
- So what I'm asking you is
if you can grant me
that what I just told you
is true about gas prices-
- I will grant it to you.
- And inflation,
that it is true:
inflation was here when
he got into office,
then it went here,
now it is down a little.
- Over 8%.
- Right, his argument
is that it's down,
but it's like no, it's not
down from when you took over,
It's down from the peak
of it over the summer.
- Yeah, and the implication
of that as it's causal,
like he caused it,
like there's some
policy position or
the fed or something.
- Which is also
dangerous that they think
as political beings
and as presidents
that everything that
happens is because of them,
which is also nonsensical.
But what I'm asking
you specifically
is in terms of the
manipulation of truth
that they're all
constantly doing,
what do you think
we do with that?
- Boy, that's a
fantastic question.
You know, I think,
that's one way to bridge
the liberal conservative
Republican-Democrat divide,
is just stop denying reality.
I mean,
one of the things that jumped
out at me in that talk,
and I don't know if,
I think you've had Heather
McDonald on the show.
- Oh, many sometimes.
She's gonna come on
in a couple weeks.
- Yeah, okay.
So she's great at this.
Matt Thornton has a great book
"The Gift of
Violence" about this,
when he was talking
about the police
and the role of the police
with young Black men,
I mean, that was just so
contrary to what the data is.
Since George Floyd,
homicide rates among Black
men have gone up 50%,
in my own city of
Portland Oregon,
they've gone up well over 200%,
and that's another story,
I'm happy to get into it, but
that's another story together.
Death by young Black men,
the number one cause of death
is other young Black men,
and that's the only true
for those quote-unquote,
"Racial groups."
And so I think denial of
reality and not stating,
we need to be blunt
about facts and evidence
and not couch them
in political terms.
Now, when he talked about,
you know,
whatever his value systems are
and how you can
solve the problem,
that's another thing.
But to blame the
police for this,
or to say that the
police are causally,
you know, I can't remember
exactly how he framed it.
And not only is that it's false,
that's just complete
denial of reality.
- Well, not only is it
a denial of reality,
but I think he does
it as a bit of cover
because he can't lose
his radical base.
- Okay, so that's the thing.
- That's a political thing.
- Okay, so that's the thing you
need to signal to your base.
And so I think that there,
so I lost just, just as a side,
I lost 1,000 followers
from my tweets last night.
- Last night. (laughs)
- Which I thought
was kind of funny.
- I hope I got
one or two for you
when I was kind of
making fun of you.
- Yeah, no,
I just kept laughing about it
because, you know, one,
it's good to not be captured
by your own audience,
audience capture.
But the other thing is I
think if you are not willing
to cross the line and say,
look, if somebody
does something,
not everything Ron
DeSantis descend,
if you're a lefty,
does is bad or not everything,
but so many people,
they're just not willing
to cross the island,
say, "Look, this is
true or this is false."
And you know, Harris was up
there robotically clapping
at these idiotic things
that are clearly
divorced from reality.
I don't know in a
two-party system
what the solution
to that is given the penalty
for crossing the aisle.
Andrew Yang and
others have suggested,
well, there is no solution,
you have a third
party, et cetera.
I don't know what
the solution is,
but I do know that
the environment is
so toxic right now
for even saying you agree
or not only even that,
platforming, going
on someone's show,
just talked to Brian
Keating this morning.
You know, even going
on someone's show
when he did the PregerU videos
and the grief people
have gotten from that,
that the left then
won't have you on,
'cause it's Konstantin
Kisin is another example.
- I'm another example.
- You're a perfect example.
- I used to be able
to go on all sorts of things.
- I owe you an
apology, by the way.
- Uh-oh, what is that?
- I owe you an apology,
maybe we should say
this off the air.
- No, no, no.
Do it on air.
- You know, you used
to tell me that,
you know this whole
shadowbanning from
Twitter and stuff.
And I'm like, ah,
dude, please come on.
But it turns out, you
were completely right.
Like you were telling
me that all along,
and I'm like, you know,
I wasn't thinking it
was a conspiracy theory.
But now, Jack goes before
com, he basically lied.
- He lied.
He lied under oath.
- I hope they get
him for perjury.
- He lied under oath as-
- He lied under oath.
Correct.
- As we're taping.
Well, the thing is,
and what his lawyers
will get him out of,
and why no one ever goes
to jail on these things.
- 'Cause they didn't
call it shadowbanning.
- Yes, exactly.
It was a linguistic trick.
They never called
a shadowbanning.
What did they call it?
They called it,
what do they call it, guys?
- De- something.
- It was de-escalation.
- [Crew Member] Visual.
- Yeah, visual filtering
or contextual filtering,
something like that.
So they were just playing
with language
constantly to get away.
- Well, that's the other thing
everybody does is bamboozle
everybody through language.
The woke crowd are
particularly good at that,
they just bamboozle people.
- So, okay.
So, I have a feeling we
probably have less disagreement
on some of the policies
than we may even think.
But on the race one,
specifically in that moment
where he talked about
how when you get pulled
over Black and brown people,
my children never had to be told
that they had to keep
their hands on the wheel
and blah, blah, it's like.
- I was actually told that.
- Yeah!
That's what I said in
my show this morning.
The first time I went
out driving with my dad,
we went to H.B Thompson
Middle School parking lot
to go drive out there
is because you know, has
a big area I could drive.
And before I even
started doing anything,
he said, "David if you
ever get pulled over,
you keep your hands on."
- He called you, David.
- Yeah, He called me David.
He still calls me David.
You keep your
hands on the wheel.
And the fact that Biden
went out of his way
to racialize that.
- Totally, so.
- And also Black and
brown the implication
being that somehow this insane.
- Yeah, 100%.
- Indian people.
And it's just.
- So I don't know if you,
have you had Wilfred
Riley on your show?
- No, I've met him a few times.
- Oh, he's fantastic.
The hate crime hoax and
stuff, I mean, fantastic.
- What a shame that we
have to live in a society
where I have to say to you,
well, he's a Black academician.
Like that shouldn't
have literally
anything to do with it,
but he has some great data.
- Should I tell you about
my Black friend Larry Elder?
Will you feel better
about this, though?
- Right, see, right.
That's the other kind
of point of commonality,
what should we do?
Is we should be able to agree
that there's a truth of the
matter independent of whatever
immutable characteristic
you possess, right?
So if we can't agree to that,
I mean, it really isn't
conventional at that point.
But the fact that
we consistently racialize
this as a problem,
but here's my pushback on that
because so many,
and I do that thing
from my YouTube channel
where I go out and I ask
random people questions,
and I put 'em on a line
from neutral to strongly
agree and strongly disagree,
and they walk to the side.
- What do you call
that, by the way?
- Spectrum Street Epistemology.
- Yeah, we're gonna link
to the channel below.
- Street epistemology
from my first book
I was in Eastern Europe,
it's better to be ruled
by the USA than Russia
or the USA than China,
all kinds of questions:
homosexuality, abortion,
trans, everything.
But consistently,
one of the things
that I find in that
is when I talk to Black
people, not African Americans,
but Black people,
they're pissed,
they're not even
deeply concerned,
they're worried, they're fed up.
And I think we need to have
an honest conversation,
like, is that imaginary?
Like, are those
concerns they have,
how rooted in reality are they?
- Well, which concerns
are you talking about?
When you make the
distinction you said,
"Not African American."
- Totally.
- So you're talking about
when you're in Europe or?
- Well, people, for example,
who just have dark skin.
So in Europe, for example,
they're not African Americans
'cause they're not Americans.
- Right.
But that's one thing
I consistently find
is that they are mad,
they're frustrated,
they don't know what to do.
And I think we need to
have some kind of an honest
town hall debate that
isn't captured by lunatics
for what is the nature of, like,
I don't like to use
the word grievances
'cause it's so fraught,
but what are the
perceived problems?
And what can we
do to help people?
- So what are you
hearing as a perceived?
What would be that
someone's angry about?
I mean, I can go through
the list of watching MSNBC
and I know what Joy
Reeds screaming about,
but gimme like an
average person.
- Yeah, so the list says
that they don't have
the same opportunities
that white people have.
And I think if you look
at the demographics
of school systems and the
funding of school systems,
they're right.
But I don't think
it's on racialized,
I think it's on economic lines,
and then the mode, if you will,
the distribution happens
to be that more poor people
are Black than white as a
percentage of the population.
But I think it starts.
- We'd also have to
talk about why that is
because more Black
people were educated
and in two-parent homes
until the welfare state
in their early '70s.
- Thomas Sowell.
- Thomas Sowell
has been writing about
this say forever.
- Correct, correct.
- So it has a lot to do
with the Democrat policies,
not just that the system
is inherently racist.
- And so how do we speak
bluntly about facts and evidence
without having the
Democrats go berserk
or the Republicans go berserk?
How do we just say,
"Listen, this is the data,
we need to make
the best policies
based upon the best
available evidence
without people losing
the freaking minds?"
Like, I don't know.
- Oh, I do have
a theory on that.
- [Peter] No, go ahead.
- I mean, it's what we're
doing here in Florida.
- Which is?
- We have a highly
competent government
that is run by someone
who is clearly articulating
what their beliefs are:
and when they try to bring
crazy transgender identity
into schools,
nope, we're not gonna do that;
when they try to
connect woke ideology
to African American studies,
nope, we're not gonna do that;
we're not gonna let a place
like Disney which is pushing-
- Zero tolerance for madness.
- Yeah.
And so I think that that
actually is the only answer.
I don't know at
a societal level,
a countrywide level.
I don't know that
you can scale that
or at least from the top.
- I guess my concern is,
and I haven't been
following that closing,
my concern is I would
wanna make sure that
no speech would be
quelched in that process.
So if you wanna have
someone spouting some idiocy
like critical race
theory, that's fine.
And I know I have
significant disagreements
with people on this.
You know, I think
I initially said,
"If someone wants to
scream about phonology,
about the earth being
5,000 years old,
but these are dangerous,
divisive, toxic,
and racist beliefs."
- There's also a difference
between talking about
them and teaching them.
You can talk about the Nazis,
you wouldn't want to
teach Nazi ideology.
- Correct.
And testing people in terms of
the right ideas that students
that answered back
that accords with the
ideological precepts.
So I'm concerned about that.
So you gave me your solution;
I'm gonna give you my solution:
so my solution is burn
the whole thing down.
My solution is that we
need to build new things,
we need to build
new institutions.
I'm gonna burn a tremendous
number of bridges
when I say this,
(chuckles) I'm
just gonna tell you
because I'm an
easy-to-speak blocker.
- You're in a burning mood.
- Well, I've been in a burning
mood for quite a while now.
(both laugh)
And I don't mean burn them
down physically, of course.
I mean, let them
fall into further
delegitimizing themselves
because they're not legitimate.
- Basically, you're
saying give them a push.
They're on the way anyway.
- Yeah!
So every single
attempt at saving them,
or fighting for free speech,
or this guy got canceled
'cause he showed the picture
of the Prophet Muhammad,
which by the way is on Wikipedia
that now certain
countries don't want on.
And if you look at
the Islamic Wikipedia,
still, if you go to
the museums of Turkey,
there are drawings of the
Muslim Prophet Muhammad.
But bracketing that
for as an aside,
any attempt to fix
or solve the problem
is only slowing it down.
The problem cannot be solved:
we have tremendous
DEI bureaucracies;
we have people who
have jobs for life;
we have College of Education
that are the worst of the worst.
We have to build new things,
we have University of Austin,
Ralston College,
Peterson is building
a new platform.
That's the solution
to this problem.
Let them get what they deserve.
- Well, A, I agree with that,
I had Steven Blackwood
in that very chair
talking about Ralston,
and he's obviously
doing that with Jordan,
what's happening
here in Florida,
now, with Chris Rufo is
gonna sit on the board of,
I believe, it's a new
school on the West Coast.
And they're gonna try to
fix what's going on over,
'cause even in Florida,
our institutions were
captured by this stuff too.
I mean, as someone that you
care deeply about academia,
I mean, how important is it
that kids even go to
college at this point?
- I think, well, let me
just back up and say,
wokeism is a universal solvent.
It will destroy everything
and anything it touches,
and so I'm incredibly
sympathetic to having a zero,
like the Hungarians
have a zero policy,
there's like, we're
letting none of this,
and like, zero.
So the best answer to your
question is what I told my kids.
You know my kids.
I told my daughter, who
wants to go to college,
"Don't do it, be
an electrician."
Oh, that's the other thing
I tweeted last night.
We need to be talking more
about vocational education.
- Absolutely.
- Vital.
- What did your daughter
say to that?
- She entertained it but
she wants to go to college.
And I can't say that
I'm disappointed,
like, you know, I want her to
live her life and pursue it.
My parents paid
for my education,
although, at the time,
it wasn't an ideology mill.
But I think my advice
to young kids would be,
and it's not to go
to a conservative
university like Liberty.
The solution to this stuff,
to ideological capture is
not to create institutions
that have the opposite ideology,
the solution's to
create new institutions
that are truth-based,
that have genuine
intellectual diversity.
So my suggestion
would be to send your
kids to vocational school.
- Yeah, it's interesting
on the Liberty front,
I'm only mentioning this
because I was invited there,
I spoke at their
Sunday Convocation.
14,000 kids, huge, huge,
absolutely huge, 14,000,
they know I'm married to a man,
they know, as I still
describe myself,
but begrudgingly pro-choice,
there's a couple other
things that I certainly
am not a traditional
conservative on:
standing ovation
from these kids.
Spent the entire day
walking around the school
while taking selfies with kids.
- Yeah, I wanna give
you a hug for that,
but we're on (murmurs),
I think Lindsay was the only
person who was an atheist
who's ever been invited
to speak before that.
- So what does that tell you
then about the conservative,
even in this case?
And you as a guy that
wrote a book called
"A manual for
Creating Atheists,"
you spend an awful lot of time
around religious people now.
- Awful lot.
- You spend an awful lot
of time around
conservatives now.
- They're primary
allies right now.
- So your primary
allies seem to be,
from what I can tell,
Christian conservatives.
- Correct.
- And sort of
more, I don't know,
people from maybe a more
nationalist political camp
certainly than you
consider yourself from
or something like that,
so what do you do with that?
- Or people like Marc Andreessen
who just basically think
that the system is corrupt
like I do, and we need to build,
you know, that's the new
culture war, by the way,
legacy institutions versus
building new things,
like Substack versus
New York Times,
Wall Street Journal, et cetera.
Locals, perfect, 100%.
- Some people have been
building new things, yeah.
- Well, you're a builder.
I lost the thread of
the conversation, what?
- So, well, this odd alliance
that you're now in as someone
that you were literally
your mission at first,
at least at one time
was to create atheists.
I also do wanna talk about
how the atheist movement
has seemingly collapsed,
but let's pause on
that for a second,
but that your allies
are now the people that you
maybe used to wanna convert.
- Yeah, so, I think, well,
I've never converted anyone,
I just gave them the tools
to convert themselves,
just to be clear.
So I think that
this culture war 2.0
is very different from 1.0,
and I published a piece in this
in the American Mind years ago,
but, excuse me,
we're unified in objective truth
that you can figure
out what it is,
that you can find it.
We're unified on the
rules of engagement,
so the rules of engagement
is if someone gives a talk
and you don't like the talk,
you don't blow a
bullhorn at the talk.
Like there are rational civil
ways to adjudicate disputes,
you know, legal
mechanisms, framework.
If you don't like the
statue here in Miami,
I don't know,
in Portland, they
destroyed a deer statue.
Great.
You go through democratic means,
I mean, I couldn't care
less what statues are there.
"But you don't take the
law into your own hands."
To quote, Judge Judy.
So there's an agreement
that there are mechanisms
that we can go to figure out
how to solve civil
issues, civil disputes.
So that's the other thing.
- So are you shocked though?
Even at this point,
even though we've been,
if people go back and watch
our videos from six years ago,
they'll find us talking
about these same things,
me from a more lefty
perspective as well.
But the point is,
are you shocked that there's
virtually no liberals?
Obviously, not none,
and Bill Maher is doing it
and I know you know
two or three others.
But what you're talking about
are their liberal principles
not defended by liberals.
- That's correct,
that's correct.
And I think that
what conservative and
liberal is has shifted,
but I'm gonna suggest
a new access to you,
the new access is,
Andrew, my friend Andrew,
our friend Andrew Doyle wrote
about that book in his book,
"The New Puritans,"
the access of the way to
think about these problems
isn't liberal
conservative right, left,
it's authoritarian,
non-authoritarian.
And the most important
thing is cognitive liberty,
we have to enable people to,
like in London,
they're arresting
people for praying.
I mean, I think anybody should
be able to talk to themselves
anywhere they want,
if I wanna talk to myself,
it'd be a little odd
if I started talking
to myself right now.
- Right now would
be (speaks faintly).
- (laughs) The idea that you
would arrest somebody for that.
You have a group of
people, the woke people,
the dominant moral orthodoxy,
who wants to tell you
exactly what to think
and if you don't think
it, you're a problem,
that we need to some kind
of a struggle session,
we need to somehow correct this,
we need to intervene,
we need to have
government sponsorships,
programs, interventions.
I suggest the access
in the culture war
is best thought of
as authoritarians
versus non-authoritarians.
- So, basically, there's
authoritarians or libertarians,
not meaning you're a
card-carrying member
of the libertarian party,
but you either want control
or you don't want control.
Something to make you feel okay.
- Yeah.
And I wanna let people pursue
whatever lives they wanna lead.
I think this thing
that keeps me.
- But so you acknowledge that
that is far more
rich on the right
or the conservative side
of the aisle now, right?
- I will acknowledge that the
left has a terrible problem
that is unthinkable among
traditional leftist,
that it's been
parasitized by wokeism,
it's been parasitized
by an invasive ideology,
I wrote about that
in my first book,
that is not inherent
in the left.
And you know, it's
guilt by association,
it's not even guilt
that I'm here,
it'd be like somebody else
won't talk to me, 'cause,
oh, I've been on
Tucker Carlson twice,
oh, you were on Rubin's show.
Well, so what?
So, yeah, there's no question
that there's a tremendous
problem with that.
- So it seems to
me that the inmates
are running the
asylum on one side
and there is another side
now that is doing basically
what you're asking
that perhaps you have some
political disagreements with.
And as I kind of went through,
I think those things
will just kind of become
less and less over time,
I think that's just the
natural entropy of it.
But what would you
say is a problem?
What do you see on
the conservative side?
Now, look, I'm married, I'm gay.
So there are obviously
traditional religious
conservatives
that are not thrilled
with that, for sure.
- To be sure.
- And yet I have found
most of them to be the most
loving, pleasant, interesting,
decent welcoming
people on the planet.
- I'd probably even
add supportive to that.
- Yeah, yeah.
So what would be something that
you're seeing as a red flag
on that side that you're like,
oh, this is where you
guys are just absolutely
getting it wrong,
this is where I cannot vote
for the same people
that you vote for,
tell me about that.
- I'll tell you a few things.
We'll bracket the
gay marriage thing,
and we'll bracket
the Ukraine thing
'cause that's another thing,
that's another can of worms
I don't wanna get into.
In terms of domestic policy,
I would say it's one of the
reasons I still consider myself,
well, I consider myself
a classical liberalist,
I believe every citizen, every
person born in this country
has certain entitlements,
I believe that they're
entitled to a public education
or the first-rate,
all the John Rawls,
I believe that, up to age 18,
they're entitled to at least
two square meals a day.
I don't think people should
be discriminated against
educationally in terms
of their zip code
or where they're from,
or they color it their skin,
or their religious beliefs.
- But hold on, I just have
to pause you for a sec
'cause I'm not sure
what conservative
believes in anything.
They may not wanna fund
certain things through
the government.
- Okay, then, I'll tell you
the other substantive
disagreements.
Let me just say it real quickly,
then I'll put a pin in that.
I also believe that
that includes healthcare
for people up to 18,
possibly 21 is a compromise.
I don't think anybody
should be sick or dying
because in this country,
if they're a citizen,
if their parents can't afford
adequate healthcare for them,
insulin, which Biden discussed.
So I think that's one of the
things that separates me.
And you see, you know.
- I wanna just clearly get it.
So it seems to me you still
believe that the state
has some role in education
and in healthcare,
and you feel that
the conservative side
or the Republicans just
simply don't believe that.
On the school choice
one that you said there,
where that you want them
to choose to go to school,
that's clearly a
Republican position
not a democrat position.
- Okay, I'm talking
about funding of K
through 12 education,
but there's a guy on my board,
National Progress
Alliance, a nonprofit,
who's a conservative,
a atheist
conservative, you know,
I think is "Suicide of
the West," Jonah Goldberg,
first line of the book is,
"There is no God, he's
a arch-conservative."
He had a really
interesting proposal:
he wanted to turn every
school in the City of Portland
into a charter school of choice.
So they all had their missions
and they could choose.
- Great.
- So that's what
I'm talking about.
We can have a compromise
on this stuff, right?
- Sure.
- So each parent would be-
- But what I'm saying is
you're taking what I think,
yeah, okay.
- So each parent
would be given an
amount of money, right?
And then they could go to
whatever school they wanted to.
Of course, many on
the left went berserk,
and they said,
"Well, what if you
wanna go to a school
on the other side of town?"
Okay, look, I mean,
this system isn't,
like, you can only do what
you can do to make things.
- But I think you're
making my argument,
are you not?
Because my question was
what are sort the
red-line issues that
you don't agree with?
- The defunding
of public schools,
I don't know if you wanna,
socialized healthcare.
- Okay, so, you want the
government definitely
involved in healthcare,
and that seems to
be pretty different.
- Up to 18.
- Yeah, okay, all right.
- But I can go for 21.
- Right, the school one, I
think, you're making more
of the conservative
argument on school choice.
- Well, I wasn't,
I was bracketing the school
choice as a possible compromise
because the federal
government still has to,
or the state government.
So we need to also do away
with the zip code idea
like that the zip code you're
in determines the school.
- Absolutely.
School choice,
funding students.
- That's a poison,
that's a poison.
Because that guarantees Bush
had no child left behind,
that guarantees the kids get,
who are poor, particularly,
and I don't think
it's a racial thing,
get trapped in failing schools.
So we need to be
more thoughtfully
and work with people
across the aisle
who hold different opinions.
But those ideas,
you know, in the far
right, the extreme right,
I don't even know what
that means anymore,
but you have people
who want the defunding,
the libertarian side of
the public school system,
so that's two differences.
Other differences,
abortion, for example,
but you know, that's
a thorny issue.
I'm not sure how,
especially with the new
Supreme Court decisions
and the state choices, and so.
- So, you're
obviously pro-choice.
- I am.
- How did you feel about
the Roe v. Wade decision?
Just kicking it back to the
States where it was originally.
- I wasn't happy.
I wasn't happy about it.
You know, one of the
things I do in those videos
where I go around, I ask people,
I do a lot about
abortion and I'll say,
so they'll start on the
neutral line and I'll say,
"Abortion should
be allowed legal
up to the first trimester."
And they'll go from strongly
agree to strongly disagree.
And then, I'll say,
"Abortion should be legal
in the second trim."
I reset them at
the neutral line.
And then I'll say,
"Abortion should be legal
in the third trimester."
And then I'll say, I
did this at Dartmouth,
"Abortion should be legal
up to the last day."
'Cause, you wanna see what it
takes to get people to move.
And a shocking number of people
will not move up
to the last day.
So, I think abortion
in the first trimester,
not constitutionally protected,
but federally protected
would be a compromise.
And then-
- Wait, sorry,
what do you mean by that?
Not constitutionally protected,
but federally protected.
- Well, yeah,
federally protected so that
there would be a legal right
for women to have an abortion
in the first trimester.
- Right, so, to me,
what Florida has done,
and I can always bring
everything back to Florida
'cause I really think that
we're doing it so well here,
we have 15-week ban.
DeSantis signed that,
and the legislative passed it
before the Roe v. Wade
decision came down.
- Correct.
- And what's fascinating
about that was,
here we have this state
that is now super red,
it is the leading
Republican state
in the union.
- Correct.
- And it has 15 weeks,
that's three and a half months.
Having two kids now,
I know an awful lot about
that developmental stage,
heartbeats and all
that kind of thing.
Nobody was going
crazy over it here.
And this would prove my point
on the conservative side,
the conservatives here
are actually just taking
the liberal position
of 25 years ago.
Meaning every sane
liberal of 25 years ago,
a Bill Clinton 1996 liberal
had some moderate
position on abortion,
there's gonna be a cutoff.
It's the Democrats
that went bananas
with eight-month abortions
where Florida, right now, again,
the reddest of the red state
has the 25 year ago
liberal position
and that is now
the conservatives,
which, by the way,
would piss off
the most conservative
conservatives.
- No, I think you see
that in so many things.
But you know, one thing you
said that I'm thinking of,
you mentioned heartbeat?
- Yeah.
- You know that in Hungary,
it's a law that before
you get an abortion
you have to listen to
the fetus's heartbeat.
Isn't that interesting?
- Which according
to Stacey Abrams,
it's not an actual heartbeat,
it's an echo of some sort of.
But what does that tell you?
Even that right there.
So, the argument you're making
from your liberal perspective,
is the policy of the most
conservative place in America
to some extent.
- It tells me with that,
and with censorship, you know,
the NWA or whatever
you wanna say,
that, you know,
that those policy positions
have had a large-scale shift.
Now you've been saying
it for a long time,
to be a conservative means
to defend liberal values.
And I think that there's
a profound truth in that
and that we have far more,
not we, but the general,
we have far more in
common than people think.
- So, okay.
I think most people watching
this are probably going,
"All right,
I tend to agree with a little
more of Dave's politics,
but Pete's making sense."
They wanna live in a country
with someone like you
the same way they
wanna live in a country
with someone like me.
But what we're still
dancing around, I suppose,
is what do you do?
Well, first off,
how do we quantify how
many woke people there are?
And what level of
power they still have?
Because that stuff is
still in the speeches,
it's in Biden's speeches.
- Hold on, hold on,
before we get to that,
I would argue that virtually
everybody wants to live
in your America and my America
because your America and
my America are the same,
they're identical in,
I would assume,
at least one way:
you want people to have liberty,
I want people to have liberty;
I want people to make
their own choices
and be responsible
for those choices;
I believe in truth,
you believe in truth.
We might disagree about Biden
slurring or whatever it is,
but we wanna live in a society
that basically has
the rule of law.
And I got something to eat
before I was coming over here
and I was walking out,
and some guy tried to chop me
for no reason.
- In Miami?
- Just right down the block at
that supermarket down there.
Some guy just tried to chop me,
but so I think that your
America and my America,
the Americas that
we are living in
have far more in common
than people think.
And I think that these
policy decisions,
those things can be worked out,
we can figure that stuff out.
- Well, it seems to me that
the sort of slight
disagreement here
is you still think
that there's a little more
utility for the state,
or at least at the
federal level than I do.
- I do.
- And I accept that.
I would also say
that if it worked,
- Particularly with
the welfare of minors.
- Fair enough.
So Peter Thiel once
said something to me
that really rung true to me,
he said,
"I wouldn't be a libertarian
if any of it worked."
And I think that that
maybe is the position
I'm coming from more,
so I like government when
government is effective,
and competent, and efficient.
That's what we have
here in Florida.
When you have this other
endless sucking machine
that is taking
money from everyone
and resources from everyone,
and spending $10 billion
to study asexual monkeys
and their relationships
to blind frogs.
- There's no question.
You know, 1/3 of the tax is
collected in 2020 or 2021,
yeah, 2020 went to pay the
interest on the deficit,
that's insane, that's insane.
Everybody's screaming about,
you know, sustainability,
that's the most
unsustainable thing,
and wait until the dollar
doesn't become the
global currency reserve.
- Right, wait til China says,
"Hey, we'd like you
to pay off our debts."
It's a good thing we have nukes.
So, okay, so understanding that.
I think you're right about that.
And by the way,
when I did Bill Maher's podcast,
and we disagreed on a
whole bunch of stuff,
actually, more than you and
I are disagreeing out here
'cause he really has this
wild stuff with Trump still
and whatever.
What he said at the
end was, he said,
"If you and I are not within
the acceptable boundaries
of what a society can tolerate
as differences of opinion,
we're totally screwed."
I mean, I think
that's the right-
- 100%
- Approach on that.
But what do you do for the
whatever amount of people
the woke thing has infected?
It continues to infect people.
- Horrible problems.
- And we're in a race,
it seems to be,
we're red-pilling
people left and right.
I see this happening all the
time with my own audience,
and then I go to
the supermarket,
people saying to me,
"Dave, I didn't believe any
of this stuff two weeks ago
then I saw your show."
- I just had
the same experience.
- Right, and you do it.
You're literally
doing it for a living.
- This is all I do.
- But the race is what
I'm talking about.
So we're red-pilling.
Okay, fine, we're getting
people to see reality.
The woke thing's still
infecting all of those things,
as you said, "It gets in
that system and destroy."
So how do we quantify
where are we winning?
Are we losing?
- Okay, so we gotta slow down.
- Yeah, okay, I'm
giving you a lot,
I'm giving you a lot.
- So let's talk about
what the woke control,
they have complete control
of the university's systems,
they have the DEI
bureaucracy, et cetera,
they have control of
most legacy institutions.
The two things that
almost nobody talks about,
because almost nobody
knows that they control,
and the damage that they do
is they control colleges
of education and Wikipedia.
So, let's break
that down if I may.
So, I can't teach with all
my publications, the years,
et cetera, doctorate, et cetera.
I can't walk in a
classroom and teach,
you have to get a
teaching certificate,
teaching certificates
in this country,
and I'm gonna say this and
people are gonna be like,
"No way, that can't
possibly be true."
Actually, Peterson
spoke about this.
- I think he's working on some.
- Yeah, he's working out there.
He's working on this.
Yeah, it's predicated upon a
book from a Brazilian educator,
Paulo Freire, the
pedagogy, the oppressed,
the idea is that you teach
to liberate people from,
he didn't say perceived
but perceive oppression
as opposed to teaching for
anything else like the truth.
We've educated an entire
generation of teachers,
pre-service teacher
education programs.
Future teachers go
into the classroom
and teach to demean truth,
and to uphold certain
non-falsifiable ideological
ideas like lived experience,
so lived experience,
Trump's objective truth,
et cetera, et cetera.
So, that's an enormous problem.
And the reason that's a
problem is even if you could
take out all wokeism,
like you literally extricated it
from all K through 12 schools,
it would just repopulate
because the teachers
will go back in.
And that's the other reason
why we need to build new things
like the University of Austin,
is because we need
teacher training programs
for people who have
not been indoctrinated
into the tenants
of woke ideology.
Okay, so, the second thing
that nobody talks about
is that Wikipedia is woke,
the editors of Wikipedia.
- Oh, yeah, it's wild
and out of control.
- Yeah, and so we're gonna
do something on that,
that breaks that down
and explains the racket
and the scam that it is.
You know, my Wikipedia page
is consistently vandalized,
it's hijacked by a few people,
yours is as well, I've looked.
Okay, so we got
those two things.
It is almost impossible to
underestimate the degree
that woke infiltration
has played in society
in our institutions.
- Look, having spent a few
days with Elon at Twitter,
he knows that there
were bad actors.
- Yeah, he called it
a giant crime scene.
And it was a giant,
I just spoke to
Michael Shellenberger,
he's a good friend of mine.
You know, it was a
giant crime scene.
And the idea is
that woke people,
they get indoctrinated
into the school system,
they go out from,
well, it starts in K
through 12 because again,
their teachers get
teaching certificates
that are indoctrinated,
they go through college.
They then, because they
have the college degree,
go into positions of
authority in the society.
And then slowly but surely
the terminology comes in,
safe spaces,
microaggressions,
trigger warnings,
inclusion is a huge one that
nobody talks about anymore,
very few people talk about.
They have infiltrated virtually
every industry, economy,
they've infiltrated
the military,
they've infiltrated the
Biden with the government,
they've infiltrated
the Southern Baptist,
the Catholic church.
So the question is:
what do we do about it?
And I have a whole
set of prescriptions
that we could talk about.
- So, okay, so there's the
build new things version of it;
there's the argue with people
to show them the
light sort of thing.
- Not argue with them,
but ask them ask them,
communicate with them,
listen and communicate, sorry.
- So, but I'm still curious
about the this thing,
do you think we can outrun it?
Do you think that this parasite
that has overtaken
so many hosts,
as I always described it,
you know, the alien in
the ship killing everybody
and the doctor likes it,
in the original "Alien,"
'cause he's like it's merciless,
it's doing exactly
what it wants,
you gotta give it credit.
He feels a camaraderie with it
because it is so focused,
and it's accomplishing what
it wants to accomplish.
Do you think we can outrun it?
- 100%
I'm 100% positive.
- Even if we have an entire
generation of young people
coming behind us that are gonna
be more energetic than us,
and blah, blah.
- Yeah, it's not sustainable.
And I'll tell you why
it's not sustainable.
By design, it has no apologetic,
it has no defense built into it,
woke people don't know the
other side of the argument
by design because it's
platforming, it's Nazism,
they won't read it;
they won't look at it.
You know, not even things
like gender studies,
but there is no debate,
there is no conversation.
And when you take debate
in conversation out of it,
you just go ever further
down into a rabbit hole.
But just recently,
the last few days in the
chronicle of higher ed,
they've had pieces coming out.
Even the New York Times,
which is the wokest of 'em all,
think they hired McWhorter
to kind of save their
image, et cetera.
But you see now people
starting to question,
people starting to challenge,
people speaking openly about it.
And unfortunately,
they're doing it in the most
superficial manifestation,
which is cancel culture.
I mean, so what do we do?
What do we do about the fact
that we have ideological
capture of our
main institutions?
Well, let's talk about what
the problem with that is first:
the problem is that
those institutions
don't have any legitimacy,
Habermas called this
the Legitimation Crisis.
A lot of people,
I've been screaming
about this for years,
nobody listens,
but the reason for that is
they don't have legitimacy
because they're not legitimate
so people don't trust them.
So that's why,
to bring it back to what I said
at the beginning of the show,
we need something
we can rely on,
we need some gold standard,
something that universally
aligns us politically,
socially, morally,
and that should be the
peer-review process.
If something gets
stamped as peer-review,
we can say the best minds
have tried to falsify it,
experts in the fields
have tried to look at it.
And I also wanna
say one more thing.
- But you accept that
the inherent problem
is that the woke will
never accept that
because they will say
it is an old system.
- Right, that's why
we need to destroy it:
we need to build new things.
That's also why we need
ideological diversity.
You know, people will say,
"Well, why should I
trust the science on,"
'The science,' they'll
put in quotation marks,
"on global climate change,
anthropogenic warming
if the university is staffed
with 99% ultra-leftists?
well, they're right,
that's absolutely right.
I mean, that's why when the
Supreme Court is balanced,
you know, five, four
conservative liberals
may be a far righter
or far lefter,
that's why people are more
likely to trust those decisions.
So ideological diversity confers
a kind of legitimation
on a system.
It legitimizes a
system in a way that
simply saying it's legitimate
or have good branding,
well, now the New York
Times has bad branding.
- Well, it was all the
news that fit to pray,
now it's all the propaganda
that's fit to slur.
- Right, now it's been
ideologically captured.
ACLU, SPLC,
things we use to trust for
hate groups, for example,
we can't trust those.
And I will tell you
to repeat it again,
one of the biggest problems
that nobody's talking
about is Wikipedia.
- Well, it is a problem.
I wonder where is it being
then used that it matters.
So like I gave up years
ago trying to contact them
and try to correct things.
- There's no point.
- It's just pointless,
it's just pointless.
But where is it being
used that it matters?
Like, does it matter
that much like you think
because people are actually
trying to find out about
people and trust it.
- So I'm even
hesitant to say this
'cause now those people
who are doing this to me
are gonna double down on it.
But you know,
so I don't even know
how many books I've
written the foreword to,
I've written the foreword
to a lot of books.
I just wrote the foreword
to Rajiv Malhotra
"Snakes in the Ganga,"
I've written the foreword
to John Loftus' book,
to Lindsay's book,
tons of forewords.
But I wrote the foreword
to Dan Arrow's book,
who's now a woke maniac.
- (laughs) Yes.
- I wrote the foreword
to Stefan Molyneux book,
"Against the Gods,"
it was about agnosticism.
And of all the
forewords I wrote,
it's in there.
- That's the one they.
- Not only that,
he wrote the foreword to white
supremacist, Stefan Molyneux,
as if I'm somehow in
long-standing
collaborative relationship,
as if I'm in some kind of
cahoots with a white supremacist
to talk about whites, you
know, it's the superior race.
But those things are
incredibly damaged
because they're bundled with
the software when you get them,
they're bundled with browsers,
and so when people wanna
learn about something quickly,
they go to Wikipedia,
they're 50 edit,
this is a whole 'nother show.
The way that those
decisions get made,
the guy who edits my
page is openly Antifa.
- It's interesting because
I think you could probably,
and this is what Elon was
saying about a crime scene,
you can probably make
the same argument
for almost every big tech
company that there is.
There was a while I was
being doxed on Reddit,
and horrible things
were happening on there.
I contacted someone
extremely high up at Reddit,
like VP-level,
and they basically were like,
"You have to submit
a support ticket."
And I was like, "Well,
I'm being doxed.
I can have someone show up
at my house and kill me.
These are people who are
obsessively hating on me,
blah, blah, blah."
- [Peter] Correct.
- And then I do the ticket,
nothing comes of it.
and it's like, you guys, it's
as if the system is designed
to let the worst ideas flourish,
not as if, maybe as if,
I'm being too generous.
- It's designed to let a small
group of radical activists
who encourage
violence, who really,
there's no polite way to say it,
they're just
dyspeptic malcontent,
and I dunno what
these people do,
they must have no
lives and no jobs,
and all they do is,
like, I see the stuff on Reddit,
like, they go crazy on you,
they go crazy on me,
they're going
crazy on everybody.
So that's the thing that I also.
- I think they've helped
the trajectory honestly.
- Do you, really?
- Well, I think
they've also helped me,
like, first off, at this point,
I just don't care.
But it never stopped me,
and if anything it was
fueling my desire for success
and I didn't realize it
when it used to bother me.
Now it's just like,
all right, keep going.
I also think it's funny,
sort of like you are waking up
like Dave Rubin's
the biggest problem.
- So I think you're in
another level that I am.
Do you remember when we were
walking when we got ice cream?
Do we need?
Are we overtime?
- No, we're good, we're good.
- Do you remember
when we got ice cream?
- That was my look,
we're gonna continue because
he's doing okay this time.
- Oh, okay, this time.
- We're always 50/50 with you.
Yes, we were getting
ice cream, I remember.
- The Twitter eggs
went with my son,
and you said if a
guy came up to you
with a Twitter egg right now,
(Dave laughs)
he started screaming at you.
You remember that?
And I really thought about it,
like that was a like really,
you know, why should you?
- Wait, just to be clear,
we were walking down the street
going to get ice
cream with your son,
and we were talking
about this endless hatred
that people get online,
and I was saying how
someone across the street
just started screaming,
"People goes in as a
f'in blah, blah blah."
You would just keep walking.
- He's a Nazi is what it says.
- You wouldn't walk up
to them and engage them
and spend time with them
and all of those things.
You would just keep walking,
but for some reason,
there was this need for
people to do it online.
- With the anonymity as a cloak.
And so my fear, so two things,
my fear is always been that
I've got something wrong,
and the way that
I can figure out
if I've got something wrong
is to listen to dissenting
voices, is to listen to say.
- Which they're gonna
use that against you.
- Right.
And that's what I said
on your show last time.
I think I missed a word,
but the most important thing
is you have to figure out
whose voice doesn't matter.
Like, this is a great example,
like this brings it back
to what we talked about:
are you drunk
tweeting right now?
Like, when you tell me
something like, okay,
Dave Rubin said that,
you know, if
Dawkins contacts me,
like, I'd be, okay,
now, I've gotta stop
and think about this,
but if it's a random person,
there's no point to
even looking at it.
But I do think that
there is something,
if I could give advice
where I looked advice,
if I give advice to you,
you have to figure out
whose voice doesn't matter.
And if you're being
mobbed on social media
or people are freaking
out at you, like, so what?
Like, this too shall pass.
Like, it's just people
who have way too much time
on their hands.
You know what the other thing
I've learned going around the
world asking people questions,
like political questions
or controversial questions?
Is when you leave
the United States,
people are not looking for
a reason to be offended.
In the United States,
particularly in
college campuses,
they are hungry to be offended,
they are craving offense,
they wanna show what a
good person they are,
what a decent person,
what a virtuous person
they are by how outrage
they are that someone's
on a different line
or has a difference
of opinion from them.
I mean, you seem to have
done a far better job
of getting over,
you did it more quickly.
I'm slowly at that point,
but I have almost fully arrived.
- You mean, getting
over the nonsense.
- Yeah.
- Well, I also think if you
don't give them what they want,
which at some point
when I just was like,
"I'm never responding
to these people,
I'm never paying attention.
I'm not giving it a moment of
my public or private time."
At some point, they just
start running outta fuel
because what they also
want is the reaction.
There is nothing that makes
one of these nihilistic
happier than-
- 100%.
And that's the other thing,
they already hate you,
they short of you groveling,
which would make
them hate you more.
There's literally
nothing you can say:
they already hate you.
- The irony and I absolutely
know this is true of you,
is if someone came to me,
if someone sent me a
thoughtful email saying,
and by the way,
I get something like this
every now and again, you know,
"Dave, actually,
you were talking about
taxes and this and that,
and I disagree with you
on this, here's why"
I will address it.
I like it.
- 100%.
- We do a postgame show
on my show now where I'm trying
to get people to correct me,
genuinely.
If I screwed something up,
but that's different than
the nihilistic destruction.
- Well, that's called integrity.
That's called integrity.
- Speaking of integrity, Pete,
this is the last time
you can do the show.
- This is it.
I'm no longer a
friend of the show.
I'm thrown off, I'm known
an enemy of the show.
- Do you have anything
else you'd like to say?
A man of great integrity.
Did you see what Nancy
Pelosi after Biden's speech?
- I did.
- She said,
she does this weird thing
with her hands now too,
"He's a wonderful man,
an aspirational man,
an incredible man,
and we hug him, man."
- I saw Chris Christie too,
and again, he wasn't talking
about the dementia
thing or whatever.
Anything else I'd like to say?
- I got one for you.
- I like, go ahead.
- I got one.
But here, I'm gonna
give you a great out.
- Anything you want.
No, I had something,
but go ahead.
- You can go with that one too.
All right, I have one
more question for you
and then I'll let you give
your closing statement.
My question for you is this,
being here in Florida,
taking this entire
conversation that we've had,
the beautiful
weather, the freedom,
a system that's working,
flourishing,
getting rid of all the things
that you're frustrated with:
could a good liberal like you
vote for a guy
like Ron DeSantis.
- Who's he running against?
- He's running against Joe Biden
or he is running
against Kamala Harris-
- Oh, you mean for president?
- Or he's running against
Gavin Newsom, yeah.
- Okay, you named two
of those three people
(laughs) I have very
serious problems with.
- It seems to me he's the guy
addressing more of the issues
that you're talking
about than anyone else,
and defending people's
ability to live freely.
- So here's what I would do.
So, I would
rather than just
capriciously answer it,
serious, you're looking at
me like, "Come on, man."
No, I'm telling you.
I would look at what
his positions are,
the answer to your
question is yes,
but before I gave that yes,
I would look at what
his positions were
and I would balance those
out against the person,
you know, he was
running against.
But yeah, I see no reason why
I wouldn't vote for a Republican
if they had more evidence-based
positions, for sure.
Is that fair?
- You couched it like a
liberal, but I accept that.
- Okay, I'll take
that as a plus.
- And now I give you open
floor to end this properly,
the way you wanted to end it.
- I wanna come back to something
we said at the beginning.
If you have a disagreement
with somebody,
then you just text them
and tell 'em you have a
disagreement with them.
It's completely fine that
you and I would have a
disagreement about abortion,
or DeSantis, or even things
closer to our own heart.
And you know, if
you told me, listen,
I mean, I would have
a problem with it,
but I would have
a problem with it
within the context
of our conversation.
If you said, "Listen,
I think the fact that you
have adopted a Chinese girl
is an interracial kidnapping."
So we would have a
conversation about that.
- That might be a
bridge too far, yeah.
- Well, no, it would hurt me.
I'd feel hurt.
- In fact, that's your
actual life, yeah.
- I'd also wanna know
why you thought that.
But I think letting
friends be wrong
is one of the most important
lessons that we can have.
And I also think it makes
your life more interesting
and you have more spirited
disagreements with the people.
You know, Aristotle talks
about that in the "Ethics,"
he said, "The highest
form of friendship
is between two virtuous people."
I thought about that for
decades since I've read that.
Like, you can come to
me and I can come to you
if I think you're off base,
I will absolutely tell
you you're off base.
And I think we've had
those conversations before,
you've told that to me.
Those are the kind
of friendships you
should strive to have,
as opposed to everybody
agreeing with everyone
until you disagree
about one small thing,
and then everyone's a Nazi.
- You wanna go get drunk and
fight some random people.
- All right, well,
I don't know about the
latter, but maybe the former.
(both laugh softly)
(calm ethereal music)
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about academia,
check out our Academia playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full-episode
playlist all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.